what up space fam glozen here from anime
upper and after the latest crazy
developments in the dragon ball super
story it's high time we discuss frieza
his new evolution black frieza and how
he's way stronger than you think now if
you do enjoy dragon ball videos on this
channel i want to keep them coming
channel the same with it and smash that
like button be a smashing saiyan rather
than a passing yamcha make this the
video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball videos and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all emperor frieza has been
around for a long time originally it was
goku's legendary super saiyan
transformation that allowed him to stop
the villain that nearly completely wiped
out his race and in dragon ball z that
was more or less it but frieza's made
one of the most shocking returns to
relevancy in dragon ball super not only
did frieza come back great to challenge
a super saiyan he came back ready to
battle with super saiyan gods frieza was
so naturally strong that he never needed
to train like goku and vegeta however he
learned from past mistakes and when he's
brought back in dragon ball super he
decides to train vigorously for four
months keep in mind the z fighters had
like 14 years since frieza's demise to
train before he came back and then
frieza just used four months before he
confronted them in fact just trying made
frieza stronger than he ever predicted
to use his own words in fact goku uses
super saiyan blue against frieza and
frieza is not intimidated when
confronted with the power of a super
saiyan god frieza goes on to show us his
golden frieza form for the first time
and golden frieza does shockingly well
against super saiyan blue keep in mind
goku trained long went through super
saiyan transformation after super saiyan
transformation until he became a super
saiyan god with red hair and then beyond
that he achieved super saiyan blue at
one point it may have been hard to
believe that frieza could ever even
rival super saiyan 2 as one of the first
villains in dragon ball z to be defeated
but here in four months he gained the
power to temporarily hold his own
against super saiyan blue it's insane to
think about however frieza was premature
as goku pointed out his golden frieza
form still had a big weakness even if
golden frieza temporarily burned
brighter as goku said he also burned
more power and stamina than goku since
he didn't take the time to regulate and
master his new op form super saiyan blue
goku was still greater as was super
saiyan blue vegeta frieza's trickiness
aside meaning his getting an
unsuspecting goku lasered and destroying
the planet before vegeta finished him
off it can't be said that he surpassed
our main saiyans although he got
insanely close for only 4 months of
training even still frieza would have
been the winning survivor if not for god
intervention aka if whis didn't give
goku a temporal do-over which goku used
to destroy frieza before he destroyed
the earth by the time the universe
survival saga comes along frieza has
learned to maintain his golden frieza's
stamina thanks to mental concentration
goku agrees that if frieza helps them
win the tournament he'll fully revive
frieza so once more frieza is being
brought back into the story making him
probably the single most recurring
villain in dragon ball even at this
point frieza was considering
manipulating the gods of multiple
universes showing that in his view even
the gods weren't destined to be above
him at one point frieza and goku punch
each other and knock each other out
leading beerus to declare that they are
evenly matched right now this doesn't
last long though as goku unlocks ultra
instinct during the tournament against
jiren however golden frieza does play a
key role in helping goku to eliminate
jiren from the tournament in fact
android 17 the last man standing cites
his and frieza's plan as the reason
universe 7 won and frieza gets what he
wants he gets fully revived frieza
insists he won't change his evil ways
while goku is not worried thinking he'll
be able to deal with frieza if he tries
anything and oh boy that statement did
not age well and that brings us to the
latest dragon ball super arc the granola
arc with its insane frieza focused twist
frieza was a background character from
the beginning of this arc in the sense
that the arc dealt with saiyan history
and the heaters who worked with frieza
but planned to ultimately overthrow him
and they were going to do that by having
the dragon ball wish enhanced gas take
care of goku and vegeta and then frieza
now the funny thing for us was that we
knew this was a funny idea because we
knew that ultra instant goku and then
ultra ego vegeta were out of golden
frieza's league so this was the actual
important battle for gas not the one
against frieza however the joke was on
us as frieza does ultimately end up
being the stronger final boss force as
elix thought he would be now with the
latest chapter yes we see the wish's
effect taking its toll on gas and he
looks horrible like a zombie but and
this is important it's not negatively
impacting his strength as far as anyone
can tell he's still taking on a true
ultra instant goku and an ultra ego
vegeta at the same time and he still
appears to have the upper hand and
that's when frieza shows up and i must
say that panel where he drops in is so
epic and hype no doubt the anime version
of this will also be amazing then gas
the guy who has been overpowering goku
and vegeta for multiple chapters says
he's going to kill frieza a dude who's
as far as we know is supposed to be
weaker than our two saiyans but not
anymore for the first time since goku
turned super saiyan frieza is undeniably
significantly stronger than goku and
also stronger than vegeta despite his
brand new epic form that he got this arc
frieza one shots a pumped up gas and
ends him with that one shot he doesn't
even stay in his black frieza form but
we see him temporarily activated when he
quickly dispatches gas vegeta and goku
are shocked for their part saying in
disbelief that gas was just finished in
one blow and that there's no way that
could happen frieza continues to flex
not just power-wise but
intelligence-wise by explaining to
ellick that he knew what he was up to
and he let him live on purpose while
exploiting eleg for his army's benefit
so all this time while elix thought he
was outsmarting frieza frieza was
actually outsmarting him and since
intelligence and strategizing is all
eleg has that must sting a lot he then
points out that he knows everything
including that elek is the weakest
heater and finishes him off with one
energy blast not impressive from a power
perspective compared to taking out gas
but still the takeaway is that frieza
out muscle gas the strongest fighter in
the universe and outsmarted elec and
that's hyping up our favorite dragon
ball villain in a big way but goes on to
say that gas had become the strongest
warrior in the universe by all rights he
should have been stronger than frieza
and then frieza responds with something
i like a lot it's a great twist he says
in this universe you mean ah of course
i've been spending some time in another
dimension you see so perhaps i wasn't
being counted as part of this universe
end quote he goes on to explain that he
was in a sort of room of spirit and time
aka a hyperbolic time chamber one of his
conquered worlds had one and he explains
get this that he squeezed 10 years worth
of training there that is mind-boggling
when you consider that he unlocked
golden frieza in just four months of
training practically bridging the gap
between super saiyan all the way to
super saiyan blue if we consider that
there is 12 months in a year then he
trained for 120 months or 30 times more
than he did when he unlocked golden
frieza and jumped so far in terms of
power that he became relevant again in
the story after being defeated so long
ago by a super saiyan he then shows the
form in all its glory to her two main
characters and says meet black frieza
goku and vegeta power up only to get
quickly one shot at themselves before
they could dodge or block however frieza
purposely doesn't finish them off as the
two revert to their base forms screaming
in pain he states in black and white
that while the two of them were having
fun on this planet he managed to surpass
them and he did so in a way that he
hasn't done since goku defeated him as a
super saiyan one of the things this arc
was arguably missing was an epic villain
and it seems that ellick and gas were
sacrificed to hype up the fan favorite
frieza more than he's arguably ever been
hyped up and i'm down with that yeah it
gives the arc a sense of incompleteness
when frieza just swooped down and one
shot at the enemies and our guys as well
but it also really hypes up the next arc
which is sure to be an amazing one if
black frieza is going to be the focus in
one way or another frieza is so
confident now that even though he has
the saiyans at his mercy he pulls a goku
and lets them live saying he came in
pursuit of a different target today it's
pretty great to see frieza this
confident again then he recruits the
other two heaters and leaves the planet
just like that in the end whis appears
and when asked if frieza was the
strongest warrior in the universe that
the oracle fish mentioned we says
perhaps or maybe the strongest warrior
emerged elsewhere which is a hype
statement any way you look at it he's
not saying it's not frieza but also
raised the possibility of someone else
even stronger and what i love about this
ending is that a lot of people didn't
like the idea of people wishing they
were the strongest in avoiding the
training so it's actually refreshing to
have a character come here after 10
years of vigorous training and beat the
guy that became the strongest because of
an unfair wish it makes things right
again in the dragon ball world in that
sense meanwhile goku and vegeta are
excited to get back to training since
they clearly have to get a lot stronger
now if they hope to stand a chance
against the new frieza and anyone
stronger than him and new forms are
definitely not out of the question here
even though some people may feel a bit
fed up with the new form after new form
formula but the fact remains we all get
hyped when things like new forms happen
and the buzz around black frieza right
now is just another example of that so
how strong exactly is black frieza well
we clearly haven't seen everything he's
got we know he effortlessly one-shotted
gas the main strong antagonist of this
arc and then one shot at goku and
vegeta's new forms he didn't even break
a sweat while consecutively defeating
these three ridiculously strong fighters
keep in mind this was a goku stronger
than the one who faced jiren and a new
form vegeta and a guy who was stronger
than both of them and it's arguable that
now frieza could even be stronger than
beerus a god of destruction we know that
jiren's strengths are passed out of a
god of destruction and keeping in mind
how easily black frieza dealt with goku
who was stronger than he was when he did
pretty well against jiren it's not hard
to believe that frieza could surpass
even beerus now since mortals clearly
can surpass gods of destruction and
think about it he was foiled by god
intervention in the past so wouldn't it
make sense that he'd train until he
wouldn't have to worry about that and
wouldn't that explain why he's so
confident right now plus wouldn't that
finally raise the stakes in dragon ball
super something that's been kind of
missing since god intervention became a
thing so for all these reasons i think
that yes frieza could very well be
stronger than god of destruction beerus
now and goku and vegeta will need a
massive upgrade to defeat him an upgrade
that's practically unimaginable at this
point smash that like button if you
enjoyed this video and want to keep the
dragon ball super videos coming always
be a smashing saiyan rather than a
passing yamcha make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future dragon ball videos and
updates let me know how you feel about
the end of this arc frieza's new form
and how goku and vegeta may be able to
compete in the future do you also think
that frieza could have already surpassed
beerus i gotta say i'm hyped to have
this amazing villain back in full glory
and i think it will make for one of the
best dragon ball super arcs if not the
best because as i mentioned golden
frieza was a different story since
really both goku and vegeta could beat
him because of the form's drawbacks at
the time but now i have no idea how they
can bridge this gap and i love it we
have that to look forward to together as
the dragon ball super story progresses
but that's it for now until next time
see you space cowboys